and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and Ryan Nicodemus
is down in Florida right now he's taking
care of his grandma so today I have with
me Paul Jarvis we're gonna talk about
minimalist business models we're gonna
talk about entrepreneurship we're gonna
talk about building a small business and
we're gonna talk about Paul's book it's
called company of one it's available now
wherever you listen to or read books
these days and we're gonna answer your
questions Paul is here with me to answer
all of your questions thanks for being
here today Paul yeah no worries it's fun
I don't think Ryan exists because last
time when you came on tour to where I
live he wasn't there Matt now you and
now he's not here again you live on an
island yes and you live on an island
within an island sort of what what so so
you're on Vancouver Island yes and I was
I was doing a tour stop in 2015 in
Victoria and we were actually splitting
them up back then we were doing the word
tasting tour and when you were we went
out there it's a beautiful city but then
you don't even live in the city you live
right now
way north right while it's so but I live
in the woods outside of the city it's
awesome just to what and you move from
the actual city from Vancouver right
yeah I lived on Robson Street like you
could not get more downtown than I lived
when I lived in been what was the what
was the impetus of of making this
significant lifestyle change yeah I
think it was I don't think we realized
how much noise there was until we
removed it from our life and I mean like
the noise of being busy the noise of
just the sound of the city all the time
we had an air purifier that acted as a
white noise machine now the white noise
machine is much smaller for travel we
also there was a billboard just outside
our bedroom window so we had blackout
blinds and I just felt like I'm glad my
wife felt the same that we were spending
so much time blocking out all of the
things around us and we were like what
if we just live somewhere where we don't
have to block anything out what if we
live somewhere where it's
just peace and quiet and so yeah we we
left the city we moved out during the
Winter Olympics in Vancouver which I
don't recommend moving out during
Olympics most of the roads are closed so
it was like the worst game of Frogger
ever but yeah I the island is amazing
and living kind of in the woods where
it's just trees I think they're the
noisiest thing is raccoons at the moment
what's fascinating is you're still able
to run a business or businesses however
we wanted to define that and you wrote
this book which I really enjoyed call a
company of one what what what made you
decide that okay I need to sort of
distill down everything I've learned
about running businesses and putting it
put it into this book
yeah it was my newsletter like I've I
write a weekly newsletter called sunny
dispatches so I send an email out every
single Sunday and I usually get a couple
hundred replies and so I wrote an
article about I think was called
something like why I don't care about
growth in my business and I sent that
out that sounds to most people that when
they hear it especially in our nothing
but growth business model it sounds to
people like it's sacrilegious yeah and
it was mostly just I was like I'm just
gonna explain to people the weird way
that I run a business that probably
they're not people are gonna be like
okay whatever this is just Paul's way of
doing things and I sent it out and I got
a couple thousand replies from people
saying like I thought I was the only one
who felt this way I thought I was the
only one who wanted to challenge growth
or have different metrics for success of
my business I was like mmm I think
there's something here because everybody
on my list kind of resonated with that
so I was like okay that that seems like
that seems like that could be a book I
had a lot to say on that topic so yes so
the theory behind company of one is
unabashed growth isn't necessarily a
good thing yeah it's so growth I think
is sometimes useful like when you start
a business you need to go from zero to
something you need to have profit have
customers all that so growth does make
sense but so often we don't know what
that something is
that I need to get bigger next year next
quarter next month next week tomorrow
has to be bigger bigger bigger because
bigger equals better but it doesn't
necessarily because it adds unnecessary
bureaucracy and redundancies and some of
those things are necessary when we want
to build something that requires those
things but I think quite often we don't
ask ourselves why am i building this why
am I doing this why do I want to grow
yeah I got a 10x something I'm just
gonna find something in 10x it and I
think a lot of us get into business for
ourselves because we want more freedom
and that seems pretty good like that's
why I run a business but then we get
into it and we get into like the
machination zuv running a business and
then we're like oh this has to be a
legitimate but I don't know what
legitimate means that's why I'm err
quoting but like I have to run a
legitimate business so I need to have
like an office and then employees and
then payroll and then a CFO for some
reason and it's like we start a business
with these intentions of wanting more
freedom and then we just keep adding
more trappings and more responsibilities
on the business because we think we want
to legitimize or we think this is the
way the business is supposed to run so
I'm just going to keep adding more
because more is apparently better and
yeah the point of the book is that more
isn't necessary or more isn't the
byproduct of business success or doesn't
have to be freedom can be the byproduct
of business success because when you
have success you should have the freedom
to choose does this growth make sense to
me maybe it does but maybe it doesn't
maybe it would impede my freedom and
then I can say no to that and I can feel
better about saying no to this
opportunity or to this growth because
it's challenging or it's hindering the
freedom that I want to have in my life
the freedom that I want my business to
give myself I can tell you that after
reading the book and I realized that I
no longer was worried about are consumed
with the idea of like reaching more
people and having a greater audience for
me it really solidified the idea that if
I could add value to an existing
audience or maybe even a smaller
audience the opposite of growth is not
necessarily atrophy
but it's finding what seth godin would
call the minimum viable audience right
and and and reaching out to those people
so we've done that in a few different
ways
one as we do it this patreon thing now
where we do these maximal episodes and
it's from a much smaller group of people
you know there are a million to three
million downloads this podcast gets a
month but our patreon has what thirty
some it has about three thousand or so
people who listen to it right but we we
dive really deep in ways that I feel
it's like a comedian working things out
in a comedy club like you're not doing
it in an arena we're able to test out
new ideas and fail in front of a small
audience and then sometimes some of
those ideas make their way to a bigger
audience sometimes they're too intimate
and we can only share it with that small
audience anyway and it would ruin the
actual thing that we're talking about if
a million people were listening to that
thing it doesn't start with the Netflix
special right right and if every if
every conversation we have was broadcast
on Netflix I would feel so vulnerable
that I wouldn't be able to communicate
what I actually wanted to communicate
now we have some questions here today
our first question is from Taylor in
Boise Idaho I work for a large
telecommunications company and as you're
probably familiar with that means that
I'm constantly juggling dozens of past
buyers and email here's the thing I
really enjoy the work I do I'm not
interested in leaving but I do want to
better understand how to you incorporate
and marry the principles of minimalism
in my daily work without sacrificing
meeting my deliverable or my
relationships with my leadership or my
ability to move forward in the company
now Paul one thing that I find
fascinating about Taylor's question with
respect to your philosophy in your book
is you talked about bringing this
company of one mindset yeah this
entrepreneurial mindset into the
business world as well where you're
actually working for someone else but
you you have the the mindset of the
company of one let's talk about that
mindset a little bit yeah I think a lot
of times especially when working with a
team
you need to be really good at sharing
what your boundaries are with other
people because otherwise especially in a
company setting you're just gonna your
place just keep gonna keep getting
fuller and fuller
if you don't else's priorities are going
to become your priorities exactly so I
think if we become better at saying like
what is realistic for us to do and not
realistic for us to do because at the
end we both parties want the same thing
leadership once a good once a company to
run wants company to be profitable the
employee wants to do a good job once a
company to do well so the company can
keep going so if you come to an
agreement with like what's realistic for
me to do so if I'm not working like 16
hours a day I can do I can do my job
better I'm not always tired I'm not
always busy frantic overwhelmed if I
have a reasonable amount of work and you
have reasonable expectations for me then
things can happen things will happen
probably quicker if there's not you have
to file like 18 TPS reports for
different managers sort of thing
I give there's ways to make it so you
can do the work that you have to do and
possibly be given as you work there to
add the more autonomy you get the more
ownership people will feel over the
projects that they do and then that's
not a matter of having to spend all this
time either micromanaging the people
that are working for you or being
micromanaged by the people above you if
there's autonomy there an autonomy comes
from mastery so it doesn't happen just
like day one like I everybody has
autonomy it's like as you prove yourself
and as you prove yourself as trustworthy
and have the ability to own the work
that you're doing then you should be
given a bit more and more rein to do the
work and not be like this is how you do
the work get it done by this date but
given the opportunity to say like okay
this is the work that you need me to do
I know that I can get it done or my team
can get it done in this time this is how
we're going to do it and and trust us to
get this done because we will I find
that part of her question is that is
frustrating to me is she said I enjoy
the job that I have but then immediately
list off all the things that that she
doesn't enjoy right the the tasks the
fires the
emails and while it is true that no
matter what your job is or if you're a
company of one working by yourself there
are gonna be some things that are
tedious or administrative or even
creatively tedious you know writing a
book isn't always a hundred percent
pleasurable in fact half the time you
want to put your head through a wall
because you're like oh this isn't
working in a stupid thing and is it
delete a whole chapter I can't believe I
what am i doing I'm a fraud there are
things that happen even in in the they
have a creative payoff there will always
be the drudgery however you may be in an
environment where there's a lot of
unnecessary bureaucracy going on and
that is the sort of an tiffin antithesis
of the the company of one mindset where
it's everyone else's priorities it's
meetings about meetings it's work to
justify one's position can you talk a
little bit about how you deal with with
bureaucracy in the workplace yeah I mean
it definitely you need to walk a bit of
a fine line because you're working in a
team environment you need to make sure
that everybody feels like they're being
heard and that everybody's kind of being
taken into account with their input but
I also think like everybody's human
right like I think a lot of times in
bigger companies and I mean you can
speak to this too because your old job
was at a big corporation right so I
think that if we talk to each other like
human beings like do we need to have
this meeting like I value the work that
you're doing but like can we just send
an email with three sentences in it
instead of having a 30-minute meeting
about the meeting that we have to have
about the meeting next week I think I
can think of several times that I back
in the corporate world made things a lot
more efficient and and to do that to do
so it wasn't just like hey I'm gonna
come in and change everything I was able
to do it from a position where I wasn't
even in power I was I was a retail store
rep and I just worked in a retail store
but I started hosting these small
meetings where I would train other
people about particular products at the
beginning of each month and that turned
into eventually I got a promotion based
on that and I was training several
stores that came together and then I
brought a whole region of stores
together because it was more efficient
and it started out just by me saying hey
I'm gonna
take the reins on this because I have a
better way of doing it now I'm not gonna
come in and say look at me this is the
better way of doing things because no
one likes to be told that therefore
they're gonna be forced into changing
something but if you show them
repeatedly that something is better
here's a better way to do it so through
the meeting is like hey guys I'm gonna
have this 10-minute standing meeting and
we're gonna cover these three topics
we're gonna stay on topic and by the end
of this we're all gonna leave here with
action items and deliverables then
people might recognize like wow we've
been wasting so much time in these 90
minute long meetings that 10 minute
meeting not only is it much shorter but
it's more effective and I walk away
feeling like we've accomplished
something and we're going to actually
accomplish something from from that
meeting itself so I think that you can
you know the cliche is lead by example
but you can just it's more display by
example show people how things could be
more effective more efficient and maybe
every other email is it doesn't require
a response and and every every
deliverable can be delivered in a way
that doesn't require an entire day being
drained of all your resources yeah I
mean my favorite email closing is no
response necessary when I see that yes
and to me in my mind I before I hit the
respond button almost always I will ask
myself will this add value does this is
this response necessary I don't need to
respond back with her quick thanks to
every email
it's just clogging up people's inboxes
I'm envisioning a world one day without
email but we'll we'll figure that out on
some other podcasts Taylor I want to
give you two books to help you out here
one is I'm gonna give you Paul's book
it's called a company of one and so Sean
if you could send her a copy of that I
would really appreciate and also our
book essential was an essay collection
with 150 different essays about 12
different areas of intentional living
there's an entire chapter in there on
priorities and I think what what Taylor
is dealing with right now is figuring
out what are the priorities because
right now it's a firehose of
everything's coming at me at once
I'm busy busy busy but how do I take
these items
how do I take other people's priorities
and make sure they're in line with my
priorities we've got an entire chapter
in there about priorities so if you like
our podcast you like the audio book
version of that or if you want the book
book or the e-book we'll be happy to
send those to you as well I'm gonna move
on to our lightning round Paul now this
is where Ryan and I usually do our best
to answer every question with just a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's we call them in the show
notes so you people can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media if
they like we're at the minimalists on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and you
are at Paul Jarvis without any valves or
an L and I will put a link to your
social media in the show notes as well
but you can find all of our pithy
answers in one place now minimal Maxim's
com
Jessica puts them up there shares them
so people have well here's what we
really do Paul is we just we ramble on a
bit that we pontificate we monitor on
until we get something that is that is
plausibly tweetable so our first
question is from Demetri in New York
City
Demetri says how do I determine what
amount of social media presence is
actually having a positive effect on my
business now I have a pithy answer for
you and then we can unpack it I'd love
to hear what you have to say as well
social media can enhance your business
but it is not the point of your business
and I know for me the thing I just
talked about a second ago with the email
asking does this add value I do the same
thing with social media before I eat
something before I post something on
Facebook or Instagram the question that
I'm asking or I'm asking Jessica who
manages our social media now is is this
a way the best way to add value to our
audience I'm not just sharing a picture
of my breakfast or whatever because for
me I don't see that as adding value now
for some people you know maybe you are a
chef and that's a great way for you to
add value to an audience so it's not to
say that you can't ever do that but
social media shouldn't be and except in
rare exceptions it shouldn't be the
point of our business but I think too
often we are we're spinning a disc
an amount of time but not really get in
return on social media is that is that
accurate yeah I mean all of the all the
research that I've done and the studies
that they show that social media doesn't
really convert very high for sales like
it doesn't it helps with building things
like brand awareness or it for me it
helps with building personal connection
or sarcastic connection with people it's
really why I use social media as sarcasm
but I think that I think there's better
ways because people don't really listen
on social media they're just there to
kind of like refresh refresh refresh so
I'd rather create more meaningful
connections more meaningful
relationships with the people that I'm
trying to reach the customers or
potential customers through things like
my mailing list because then it's a
direct connection if they reply it goes
to me and then I can reply to them it's
a direct connection we're having a
conversation here so that to me makes a
lot more sense I also think that people
especially who have started businesses
recently I guess don't don't always see
that business has existed a lot longer
than social media so people are like I
can't believe you're not on Facebook or
not on LinkedIn like how do you run your
business like I started my business in
the 90s when there wasn't Facebook or
LinkedIn or Twitter there was I think
there was myspace maybe my space came a
bit later but like you don't have to use
and that's the thing like people think
oh I have to use social media because
everybody else is using social media but
when we get into situations like that
where it's we're competing with
everybody else it's really hard to stand
out it's really hard to be be above the
noise in those situations yeah I think
quite often we use social media as a
solution but we're not really sure of
what the problem is like I've got a
solution that's in search of a problem
and if that's the case then obviously
it's too much so back to Dimitri's
question what amount of social media
presence is actually having a positive
effect on my business I think if it's
adding value to your clients customers
followers etc your audience then then it
is having a positive effect or influence
on on your business however if it is
getting in the way of you actually
creating if it is a place which
you can pacify yourself or just
mindlessly consume then it's getting in
the way of what your the core of your
business or your creativity is and if
that's the case then you know you might
want to do something like what Cal
Newport talks about we had him on the
podcast talking about the 30-day digital
declutter and just removing those things
from your life and then slowly bringing
them back in so removing it from your
business is a great way to do it and
then slowly bringing it back in finding
ways that it will add the appropriate
amount of value kareem from patreon asks
how were you able to walk away from your
corporate jobs identity it seems like
society is constantly pegging who we are
on what we do it's the first question we
ask each other right it's like hey what
do you do it happened to me right before
this I was out on the patio here and
some guy was like hey what I saw your
your your studio space and that has the
minimalist on there what do you do and
I'm like oh that's an expansive question
how much time do you guys do we have a
time limit here what do you do we're
really asking is like what is the job
title on your business card so I can
compare you to me on the corporate
structure the latter the socio-economic
ladder and I can see whether or not
you're worth what communicating with and
and so yes identity is is something that
is tied up quite often in our job title
but we're so much more than our job
titles and when someone asks you what
you do I mean sure you could say I'm a
podcaster I'm a writer or I have a
website or designer or you could say all
of these things but all the things are
they're just a sliver of what you do and
especially if you pan out outside of
business it's only a sliver of what you
do as a human being so my my pithy
answer is our identities are shaped by
the costumes we wear that is actually
the first line of our book everything
that remains and I'm sitting in in in
that book I'm sitting in this sort of
business meeting at the beginning of the
book and realizing like that we're all
in this like disgusting room that is
like off-white we're all wearing these
weird white shirts and like we're pale
and this window
room and and I realized I'm wearing this
costume now part of it is the actual
costume like I'm wearing this this
uniform right but the other part is like
how I am projecting myself on on to the
world the costumes we wear and part of
that has to do with how we actually
answer the question when someone asked
me that question now I tend to tell them
what I'm passionate about
yeah I rephrase the question instead of
saying what do you do I'll say what are
you passionate about occasionally you'll
get a deer in headlights look but quite
often that it'll change the entire
direction of the conversation into
something more meaningful so how do you
handle this when someone says what do
you do depends if I want to have a
conversation or not to be honest like
because sometimes like the easiest
answers writer and that can lead to more
things but it can be yeah it depends
because I do so many things like if
somebody asked me online I just post
that the gif of Homer Simpson just kind
of shrinking into the bush like because
it's hot like it's a hard question to
answer when you work for yourself and I
remember when I started working for
myself and I told people like I'm I work
for myself and they're like well what do
you do for a job because frit like in
the 90s freelancing really wasn't a
thing and they're like well know what
agency do you accept a designer that
well what agency do you work at I'm like
a mine I guess and there's like where's
your office I'm like buy spare bedroom
but now it's like this is something that
people this is something that a lot of
people do so it's something that is a
lot more common and so now the answer is
easier to explain like if I just say oh
I'm a freelancer people like I get that
whereas in the past it was gear
freelancer what does what do you mean
you work for free it's it's funny we
have these any sort of canned answers
and I think you know Kareem might be
somewhere where she is working a job
that pays the bills and it's and that's
fine but she also doesn't want that to
be her entire identity she doesn't want
to say well I am a sales manager or I am
an accountant or whatever and so I think
I think for me quite often it's
reframing the question is what is this
person actually what were they trying to
get out of me they're probably just
trying to have small talk at this point
and that's the easiest in four
them and so what you can do it and it
takes a little bit of courage not a lot
but because it's different you're giving
them a different answer and you could
say you know what I'm really passionate
about writing or I'm really passionate
about snowboarding I'm really passionate
about surfing all of a sudden they're
like that's what you do you like yeah I
really enjoy it and they're like what do
you make a living from surfing no but
that'd be awesome wouldn't it I wish I
could no I just whatever I'm off work
it's the thing I'm most passionate about
what are you passionate about I find
that we change the direction a little
bit what we find is that it makes the
conversations a whole lot more
meaningful as long as it's a moment
where you actually do want to have the
conversation yeah all right looks like
we have a bunch more surprise questions
this week what percentage of your work
is stuff you have to do but you aren't
passionate about with employees how can
I keep our work relationship separate
from our friendship however the
minimalist applied minimalism to their
business specifically your brick and
mortar coffee shop we'll talk a little
bit about what it means to open a a
brick-and-mortar business in today's
digital world and why it's it can still
be necessary but I think quite often
it's it's a goal that is completely
unnecessary and we'll talk about the
difference and when when when does it
make sense to have a brick and mortar
business any advice on managing a high
stress toxic workplace well I'm still
here and as vague as this is any tips on
finding a more meaningful job after
feeling extremely burnt-out and how do I
tell my boss I am burnt out at work also
I want to play another round of
overrated or underrated we're gonna talk
about Apple products we're gonna talk
about Microsoft Excel this will be like
the business version of overrated and
underrated Ryan and I we just we throw
out these different topics water coolers
are they overwrite or underrated we'll
get to all that in a moment and if you
want to hear all that you can listen to
this week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
we're you're currently listening to our
weekly minimal episode but each week
Ryan and I well this week Paul and I
record an entirely different long-form
maximal episode on the minimalists
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about the
topics we don't usually discuss in
public
Plus patreon is best way for us to fund
this podcast to keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll receive a personal link
so that our maximal episodes play in
your favorite podcast app you also get
access to our entire back catalogue of
more than 100 private podcast episodes
find all the details and all the good
stuff including an additional podcast
episode every week over at the
minimalists comm slash support before we
get into that here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners I
name is Luc Pearson Las Vegas Nevada I
have a comment about fitness I'm reading
a book it's called starting strength
it's a very simple way to exercise for
people who go to the gym it's often
confusing people who like to go to the
gym it's often hard to minimalize your
fitness routine so I started to read
this book and it's simple it may not be
it may not be easy but it is very simple
um and it's implemented a lot of things
in my life my back is more strong just
everything about me stronger don't
really care about what I look like
but I feel stronger and I feel healthy
you know and I just enjoy working out
but it was so difficult before but now
reading this book starting strength by
Mark repeat oh just hope that helps
definitely if you go to the gym a lot it
will simplify your life
okay Josh and Ryan this is Stephanie
from San Antonio Joshua I believe had
recommended a book by my new favorite
author Andy Andrews and it was called
the travelers gift and that book is so
it's like the Bible another Bible
without the religion it thinks it tells
you exactly what to do with your life
exactly what you're not doing
and basically tells you that it's all on
you and that's a really good book that I
recommend to my friends and I started
reading numerous books of Andy Andrews
the noticer is another one that's really
good I think a lot of people need to
read it it's about perception about
seeing things beyond your own point of
view that one was really good I also I
don't know if you guys recommended this
or if I just happen to stumble upon it
but there's a book called miracle
morning by how I can't think it was last
night but it's written in the towel and
it is a step by step you know get out of
your funk process that you start your
morning that by 5:00 a.m. you do
journaling you created you exercising
you run your errands and it's just it's
a way to change another way to change
your life and they actually have a
community on Facebook called the miracle
morning community and there's people
from all over the world alright Joe
thanks again to Paul Jarvis for being
here today I'm really grateful he
decided to spend this time with us check
out his book it is called company of one
you can also check out his website it's
Paul Jarvis comm you can sign up for his
newsletter over there and any podcast
they should check out what are you doing
this these days in terms of podcasts
I've got a podcast called company of one
just like the book and I co-host a
podcast called the creative class with
my business partner Kaylee more further
yeah beautiful wall check those out
we'll put links to those in the show
notes as well and real quick for right
here right now speaking of coffee here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalist until recently the only
you could get coffee from the minimalist
from our coffee shops called banded
coffee co it's down the st. Petersburg
Florida was within the four walls of the
brick-and-mortar business but recently
we launched online sales for our coffee
so if folks want to get the minimalist
choice coffee we pick a new coffee every
month you just go to the minimalists dot
coffee is the website and you can order
coffee from there and it updates every
month you can check out what we are
currently enjoying drinking so the
minimalist coffee to order bandit Coffee
Coast coffee and if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us a voicemail for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalist if you want our show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists comm you'll also
receive our simple Sunday emails each
week and for our added value this week
let's listen to my favorite song from an
artist called Benjamin Francis
leftwich's new album is called gratitude
and this song sounds like the soundtrack
to the most pleasant day you've had all
year what's here tell me you started to
pray from Benjamin Francis leftwich's
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all minimus